now back to our top story senators are
still reviewing the FBI report on Brett
Kavanaugh as the partisan battle heats
up over its findings and the Senate
gears up for a critical confirmation
vote how are Republicans reacting to the
FBI's Cavanagh report well we now bring
in Senator John Cornyn from the great
state of Texas for the very latest it's
very good to have you senator you can
help us understand all of this I wanted
to ask you this do you think that the
Democrats have managed in all of this to
energize the Republicans and disappoint
their own base well I think when we
confirm Brett Kavanaugh which I predict
we will on Saturday I think that will be
the outcome of course we could have had
a more dignified way to consider dr.
Ford's allegations through the normal
process but since senator Feinstein's
said on those allegations for about six
weeks and dropped them on us after the
hearing of the first hearing on Judge
Cavanaugh we got into this I think
circus where there were no rules and the
end seemed to justify the mean so but
yeah this could have been handled much
better and I think in a way that would
have been more dignified more protective
of dr. Ford and the judge we're gonna
take it around the table sir I'm gonna
start with judge Jeanine all right
senator thanks so much for being with us
you know I noticed that you yielded your
time to the prosecutor and in the end
what you're looking for is to have the
public know what is in those FBI 302
reports now you know that that would
establish a precedent I mean don't you
think it would be a dangerous precedent
and I have an idea and that is if they
if you want to give them the FBI report
how about they give you the therapists
notes that would be that would be the
ordinary procedure as you know judge and
but the the reason why we decided to
asked Rachel Mitchell to ask the
questions of dr. Ford is because we know
we would have been criticized for having
a aging white men asking a victim of
sexual assault hard questions but we
really needed to have answers to the
questions in order
test her story as you know there's been
no corroboration whatsoever in fact all
of the people she's identified have
refuted her her version of the story but
again something happened to dr. dr. Ford
but we weren't given the benefit of her
therapist notes which I think would have
shed a lot of light on that all right
Jesse Watters hey senator Cornyn I just
wanted to know has your relationship
with your Senate Democrat colleagues on
the other side fundamentally changed
after how they behaved within the last
two months because I've never seen Chuck
Grassley who's pretty even-tempered so
animated and so angry at some of the
behavior coming out of the other side
that it looks to me like it's beyond
repair what's your assessment of your
relationship now my favorite chuck
Grassley saying is just because I'm
yelling at you doesn't mean I'm mad at
you okay
but but but if this is strained
relationships and in the trust that's
always important particularly in the
legislative process we understand that
we're adults and we've been we know what
what's at stake here you have different
views but we got we've been getting a
lot of things done under this
administration with Republican
majorities in the House and the Senate
but this process is not one I would ever
want to see repeated for anybody for any
nominee a Republican or Democrat nor for
any witness who comes before the
committee I think it's been shameful
Greg Gutfeld hey senator I have in this
process I've noticed a lot of laws being
broken but one of them was a 27 year old
Democrat intern an intern who's 27 who
talks to a number of Republicans who
were Pro Cavanaugh putting their private
information public that a fellow name is
Costco was arrested by DC Metro I want
to know what's gonna happen him but I
also want to know is anything gonna be
done with a vanetti or any of the people
that he worked with because it seems to
me he broke some laws yeah this this
daxing so-called the incident which I
wasn't familiar with the term but you
described it yeah this person who's been
now charged with this crime will be
charged with as I understand multiple
offenses
and so this is nothing to toy around
with this is serious business and
fortunately the Capitol Police and the
Metro Police are handling this serious
seriously as far as mr. a vanetti is
concerned I wasn't eager to provide him
a platform for more of his publicity
seeking obviously the allegations made
by Miss that neck nobody corroborated
those she's walked back from those
witnesses that were asked like Mark
judge about that said no way didn't
happen so again we're left with no
corroboration no confirmation of any of
these terrible allegations and the
judges unequivocal denial that it ever
happened under penalty of felony how
could he not be disbarred I mean he's
he's down the Sharpton Mason Maddox you
know phase of this a very Tawana Brawley
esque event yeah I think I think you
know the way that Miss Katz the lawyer
that senator Feinstein recommended for
dr. Ford and mr. a vanetti and others
have not distinguished themselves by
their conduct and I think perhaps the
appropriate forum for them to be
reviewed is through the Bar Association
through the ethics committee they have
disciplinary authority they can
discipline or even potentially disbar
people for advancing their law license
we have one last question from Juan
Williams
senator Cornyn you're such a dignified
guy like your life but I got a you're on
a brawl here at the 5:00 so let's start
the brawl you have politicization of the
Supreme Court I would hope that would
concern you but I know that you refuse
to look at Merrick garland you said you
wouldn't look wouldn't consider it and
now you're in a situation where
Democrats are so upset over this process
that's produced judge Cavanaugh I worry
that the court itself is going to like
so many American institutions absolutely
go down and the trust factor among
Americans yeah one since the Bork
hearings and the where Bork became a
verb and those wars have escalated with
the nuclear option by Harry Reid to pack
the DC Circuit Court unfortunately this
has gotten worse and worse I hope we've
reached the end
that and we could return to some more
dignified process both to the both of
the nominee and that would reflect well
on the Senate but this we had a lot of
hardball played and unfortunate I think
we're reaping the whirlwind well but I
think blacking you know
Merrick garland just sticks in so many
people's crowd at twice elected
president and you won't let him even be
considered you might say Cavanaugh was
unfairly treated but gosh you wouldn't
even give Merrick garland a chance a
fair hearing this is the Biden precedent
he said during a presidential election
year that you don't confirm a Supreme
Court justice if Hillary Clinton had won
I don't think we'd be hearing anything
about Merrick garland because she would
have made that appointment but because
people chose president Trump he chose
differently that's why I think people
are so upset all right we're gonna give
you the last word thank you senator
Cornyn Thank You Dana